[Musique]
à l'ombre des grandes boulangeries des
artisans créé des pins nouveau genre
des pins qui serait plus digeste que les
pains fabriqués en usine du moins c'est
ce que les clients de maxime des landes
et d'autres boulangers prétendent qu est
ce qui peut rendre un peu plus digeste
selon toi c'est pas une chose c'est
vraiment plusieurs choses que est ce que
une question de pétrissage de la pâte
est ce qu'il ya une question de variétés
de l'isc une question de fermentation si
tu vois moi dans mon expérience dans ce
que j'essaie de faire c'est un peu
toutes ces choses le cg quasiment pas
besoin de travail étant donné qu'ils
publient tanda et danser boulanger qui
prétendent que leur pain et plus digeste
parce que il travaille différemment leur
pain leur farine et leur le vin non
seulement ils ont 13 mai il devrait
avoir l'appui de toute la communauté
scientifique
tout devrait aller chez eux
le gastroentérologue michael bensoussan
rencontre tous les jours des gens qui
souffrent de problèmes digestifs
les gens qui ont un problème relationnel
de confort digestif avec le gluten c'est
10 % des gens au québec c'est à dire
cinq à six fois plus que les gens qui
sont authentiquement coeliaque
tous ces gens qui ont un problème avec
le gluten c'est parce que le gluten est
devenu dans l'industrie ce qu'il est
devenu de nos jours le gluten a changé
l'industrie alimentaire a changé
le gluten est une protéine qui se
retrouve dans certaines céréales comme
le blé l'orge et le seigle il contribue
à la texture des produits de
boulangeries et autres produits dans
lesquels il est utilisé ici je ne trie
pas là parce que je dois créer des
réseaux de gluten trop dense les
fermentation naturelle de levain avons
pris de gérer près fermenter le réseau
du thème du pain aussi est ce que on met
trop de son blé qui est en fibres
insolubles qui se digère mal sain est
aussi une question de variétés de ligne
est aussi une question de pratiques
agronomiques taxi c'est vraiment un
ensemble de choses quand tu aller
acheter
du pain tranché au supermarché dans les
années 80 les années 90 il était
beaucoup beaucoup moins transformés
qu'est ce que tu vas acheter maintenant
c'est dur à dire mais il ya presque plus
pain nan c'est pas là le peintre c'est
la farine de l'eau du levain du sel tas
de 7 c salt
tu regarderas un pain industriel que tu
achètes maintenant il ya comme 50
ingrédients y rajoute là dedans
l'industrie des édulcorants du gras du
sucre pour que ça goûte quelque chose
mais à la base le produit transformé qui
est vendu n'a rien à voir avec du pain
et le goût de palme
il y a quelques années un champ de blé
c'était pas du tout comme le fond
d'écran windows qu'on a la clé c'était
pas une grande étendue jaune pâlotte et
c'est un avis du verre on avait dû
violer on avait dû orange y en avait du
rouge c'était des blés différent
quand on s'est mis à croiser des blés
step haut que ça résiste mieux aux
pesticides pour 506 mais qui aussi que
sa race plus vos people ou de lutte ne
soit plus vite mais la personne qui a
décidé la croisée des bibelots des
concerts à son goût mettons
donc pour favoriser l'industrie et le
processus d'ultra transformation du pain
on est remonté jusqu'au début de la
chaîne de production d'avoir sélectionné
les gluten les moins digeste pour les
gens résultat 10 % des gens ne digère
plus le gluten est à peu près
[Musique]
le son comme d'autres artisans
boulangers maxime travaille avec des
farines anciennes ou des farines moins
utilisés dans la production de masse
même sens vraiment de mettre le blick la
céréale à la lan donc je travaille
plusieurs variétés de pains sont
inspirés de plusieurs variétés de blé
différents mais chaque livre peut coûter
la même affaire le corps à 100 le
bleymard qui les portent c'est pas la
même chose ça goûte pas la même a faim
c'est selon l'arrêté de licques on va
travailler ou si ces panoramas pareil au
niveau de ce ferry
quand il dit mon pain il est plus
digeste parce que je le fais faire
monter plus longtemps la raison c'est
recevable encore une fois le temps de
fermentation c'est le secret artisanale
qui va te donner des processus chimiques
qui vont se passer dans la pâte qui va
faire que les cycles de digestion ont
commencé faut que je donne la table face
à face à notre caméra trois quarts
d'heure qui a pas besoin de forcer vers
mu n'a pas quoi que ce soit il va
skritts de plus en plus les gens se
rendent compte de l'importance
dans ton corps du microbiote
le microbiote c'est l'ensemble des
micro-organismes qui peuplent notre
système digestif il joue un rôle majeur
sur notre santé ce microbiote il faut
lui donner du vivant donc c'est pour ça
que de plus en plus de gens mangent des
aliments fermentés et c'est très bon le
microbiote adore ça des quais firent du
kimchi le pain au levain ça va
exactement être la même chose faut que
les gens comprennent que le vin c'est ce
qui va donner c'est des cdc comme des
petits champignons c'est vivant c'est ça
qui va donner la vitalité au pain
c'est cool les métiers jusqu'à
l'impression d'honorer le monde de faire
vraiment une différence aussi au niveau
agronomique parce que j'achète des
farines devenir anciens dans les cas je
crois qu'ils sont d'un rituel biologique
avec l'espace et de la glande amis seuls
3 je fais le pari que si les gens
consommaient non pas 80% de pain
industriel dans leur diète mais 80% de
pain d'artisans boulangers il y aurait
plus du tout 10% de gens coréen
problèmes relationnels avec le gluten